[Music]
why don't we go next to
christian
from edmonton
uh hi david hello
um thanks for taking my calls today
pleasure um i got a question about
election systems um so of course i'm
here in canada but i'm aware that you
guys have the popular vote
interstate compact
um attempting to
you know change the way you guys do your
electoral electoral system yes
um i understand it needs you know like a
bit under 100 more electoral seats
in order to become
active
um but here especially in alberta but in
canada as a whole too we do have a
problem with gerrymandering
um just like you guys in the states okay
um as an example from our last election
in 2021
the ndps they're kind of like the
progressive party here
they received three million votes which
is
17 percent
and they got 25 seats but the block of
aqua
which only is in quebec they don't run
in any other province yes they got 1.3
million which is 7.6
and they got 32c
so
i'm it's more than just a population
thing um
so
when the trudeau government first came
into power in 2015 they ran on
proportional representation
but
i imagine they ran the numbers if we had
something like germany or japan
and quickly realized they'd lose a ton
of power
so they abandoned it
do you think making a change to the
proportional system or a popular vote
interstate compact would
fix gerrymandering or do you think it's
more systemic than that
are you saying in the united states
yeah in the us or if we in canada we
change to a proportional system there's
different these are two different things
that are in so i can only speak to the
united states in the united states
there's two different things going on
the national popular vote interstate
compact is a way to use an a national
popular vote to choose the president
without having to make a constitutional
change which is states just agree
we will give our votes to whoever wins
the popular vote so that gets us out of
the electoral college that's one thing
separately to deal with gerrymandering
which is within states in the u.s
setting up either i mean at this point
computers can fairly draw district maps
or setting up a non-partisan
you know a district redistricting
committee that would solve
partisan gerrymandering within states
and it's totally separate from the
national popular vote interstate compact
two different things two different
problems they would solve
okay so like if the interstate compact
came into effect because enough states
were able to just go on proportional
system
the the states that still gerrymander
like the southern states that do it
really bad they would still do that it
just wouldn't matter it had the
gerrymandering has nothing to do with
the presidential okay so the pr the the
gerrymandering is for district seats
within states like
what is the what is the what is the map
of aoc's district
completely separate from how we select
the president all right my friend thank
you for the call very important issue
that is going to do it for calls today i
apologize if i didn't get to you but i
will try to do better next time